what's going on there reject nation g j
here today to watch the movie nobody
you can run and watch this movie for a
while as you can see we've been doing a
lot more movie reactions here at the
real rejects as of late so subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction is up
also full length watch along where you
sync up with the time code for nobody
will be at our patreon page cover a
whole bunch of crap over there as well
thanks to all of become superjects but
if you can't do that the least you can
do is leave a like and a comment we're
very very much appreciated and then the
handsome devil's over at prepper thank
you guys so much for doing this but yeah
i love the trailer for this love bob
odenkirk can't wait for the next season
to better call saul let's get into this
[Music]
protect the cat oh
kitty where the [ __ ] are you
me
um
[Music]
come on
garbage day mr
so routine
did he get the garbage
it'll end with him getting the garment
put the phone down
gosh
now
that's about all there is
that's it i'll use a debit card
note give me your ring
give me a [ __ ] ring
i'm married to your wife now no son let
him go son
what i said let him go
yeah [ __ ] pop your [ __ ] your [ __ ]
nobody's talking to him did you even
take a swing
she had it could have taken her dad
you know if that was my family
we're gonna get out of your hair
and just leave that garage door closed
okay you're a shitty cop you know that
you're so condescending
that was my family i would risk getting
my family killed i wouldn't have been a
[ __ ]
you had a golf club they only had guns
you had it coming man
oh no
yeah i was an auditor so kind of a
nobody pretty dry story don't care i
just want to finish up the project and
call it a day what about you uncle
charlie i actually already left him a
message he tried grandpa
he actually saw some action yeah maybe
if you were his offspring
oh and um
you missed the garbage
i just really want the garbage taken out
could you put it out the night before
maybe
oh i took all the coffee
it's reasons like this why will smith
slapped chris rock
can't keep a handle on things at home
pretty cool huh
yeah the old man croaked
you didn't have much to leave but at
least i got something out of it honey
come on
at least i got this
compensation machine out of it 4.9 liter
v8
0 to 60 and i'm about to find the [ __ ]
out oh he's going to hijack that at some
point
[Music]
[Applause]
0-60 i'm going to find out here in this
residential neighborhood i was just
trying to keep damage to a minimum yeah
how's that working out for you
everybody's safe so jesus safety's on
keep my sister safe bro
they got rob from it's always sunny to
be
[Laughter]
oh good spot your son will never find
you
hey oh it's the office still okay
sorry i'm thinking you did the best
thing you could bullseye
i mean you being you holy crap that's
michael ironside i had electrical tape
on the handle
just smith and wesson
hadn't been shot in a long while
it was uh
[Music]
ha ha ha ha
now i know why you didn't do what you
didn't do
hmm interesting i know what you're
thinking about and i wish it wasn't
don't do nothing stupid hear me
the pop resembling that his own state
visualizer to pop himself oh man
better an actor movie
find it
you can't find what my kitty cat
bracelet
where was it
um here you sons of [ __ ] gonna kill
those two
i'm sure it'll turn up somewhere oh god
he snapped i think you could hear the
moment
[Music]
i all i think was a kitty cat bracelet
yeah
sensing a theme in these guys movies
there's this thing i gotta do
then you best go do it
love it love it agent mansell fbi
your id is a badge
expired by about 20 years and i'm pretty
sure that ain't you in the photo who are
you
oh she had my tattoo done just a man
i was looking for someone probably
shouldn't flash cheese like that around
here bro
there are three types of people who as
you say flash cheats
blue don't know any better people who
are seeking to intimidate and people
like me who wish with every fiber there
being that someone would try to take it
from them
oh
god
uh
thank you for your service
i'm getting out of here should have
called this movie wrist hats
i just locked us barricaded himself
smooth brother
send me in the direction of this person
oh right there louise
rico anymore
[Music]
oh my god damn
the kitty cat bracelet
give me the goddamn kitty cat bracelet
kill the baby kill it the baby
that baby has that bracelet i swear to
god
[Music]
oh why didn't you get the kitty cat
bracelet
they say god doesn't close one door
without opening another
please god
open that door
he just needs an excuse to break bad
this girl's gonna get home safe tonight
right for me
i hope these [ __ ] like hospital food
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna [ __ ] you
yeah you are
nice
house
[Laughter]
jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[ __ ]
get back up
you are now reborn
evil dies tonight
there you go buddy
[Music]
oh my god
he's going so hard on them
[Applause]
yes oh god
ah now you've done it
oh my god
oh he's choking on his own blood man
that guy's gonna die
oh no don't tell me oh no oh no
sorry about the mess
i was gonna say
maybe murdering them is a little too far
that'll be fine
hey hey
i couldn't sleep
i was thinking about the garbage
[Laughter]
it's been a hell of a day i can see that
just like old times huh
oh so she knows about his past look i
miss you
i'm always right here i feel like she's
a little excited about it
she's gonna bring a spark back
[Applause]
what a badass jay walking like that
[Music]
oh
yeah
oh my god that's so violent wow oh my
god that's so violent
oh
jesus
hey
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my
god so painful
[Laughter]
he attacked us unprovoked one man are
you [ __ ] with me
everything is a weapon
find this man
the bus has a camper
ride the metro all night and you'll find
him eventually
one of those guys was the brother of you
leave this off and you don't want to
[ __ ] with him hutch i'm serious ask the
barber he knows
it was an isolated incident
how about i make that lasagna that you
love tonight you know from scratch like
i used to it's been a while
lasagna i'd really like that
i love that little girl
it's the most beautiful ray of sunshine
writer's like how do little girls talk
exclamation
marks but what i do know is if he
doesn't know who you are yet
he will soon
what
have you got from me
i found his dad
he's got him a nursing home downtown
no
damn you can't recognize a wolf in
ship's clothing
i question the impliability of your
employment here
i think if he had his way he'd probably
walk away
with
gonna watch all this money
[Music]
no
crap no need to pay
[Laughter]
too much
i don't think you just leave russian
i mean he almost started to fire her so
you know
because you know bro
oh
no
jesus christ everybody gets in the
basement
[Music]
oh
don't call 9-1-1
bit of a video video they can watch you
very entertaining movie yeah
[Music]
oh it's gonna be gruesome oh my god
nice
hit him with the lasagna
ah very cool
lasagna smash
damn
oh cool
oh
man you're reduced to the equity of the
house
only your son got to see some of them
[Music]
oh
worth it
[Music]
yes
he would have died
just saying
and i do not ever suspend those belief
in
my movie-going experience yeah how how
much blood alone has he spat out he
pulled out he got no blood left in his
body it used to be what they call an
auditor for those three letter agencies
auditor as in the last guy any
organization wants to see at their door
i used to make sure that there was no
one left to it
bored him to death
that thing i had to go do
it escalated
heads up okay no don't let him be the
always lost moment no he'll kick their
asses too
lasagna is ruined oh
crap symbolizing
hey guys so i need your help to clean
this up
i need to take care of this what is this
it is what it is i need you to trust me
right now come on casab um
close that distance come back
deal with us then
we will see a couple's counsel right
then oh fellas
here we are
[Laughter]
three million bucks from a u.s military
base in revolto italy and his prize was
me looming over him with walter ppk no
wait
uh it was uh suppressed hnk usb
alan was living in boise idaho
he had a wife she came with two kids
nothing there to skim and he was smiling
like a goddamn buddha
[ __ ]
bone burns to ash at 1500 degrees
and this basement is designed to double
that so they won't be finding you among
the rubble it lasted a lot longer than i
expected
go take your neighbor's car
baddest ass needle drop of all time i
see trees pretty awesome
and vinyl is highly flammable good call
[Music]
[Laughter]
start a whole new life off the cribs
[Laughter]
[Music]
better have a gun or that blanket gramps
his hands are guns
please turn that [ __ ] down
[Laughter]
what a g
runs in the family
i'm buying this place we put our blood
sweat and tears into this place
breathe
breathe okay
[Laughter]
i don't give a [ __ ]
and hutch's balls grew three sizes that
day
oh no i thought he had a big-ass gun for
a
second
it's a shoulder-mounted cannon
oh
come out of hiding man he's trapped in
martin shkreli's penthouse
[Applause]
okay so he's in america i thought her
second thought that he was
back in russia
no he's nearby
[Music]
[Music]
on it
check their receipts
[Music]
jesus
does she took the pain yeah but it takes
tomorrow with you
god opened a hell of a door for you man
[Music]
oh cool
that's cool
i don't think i've ever seen that in a
movie before
[Music]
hey
what say you and i have a moment
[Music]
leave us stunt team we'd like to end our
little tattoo tape right now what's done
is done after all we can both rebuild
right
hm wait i do
i burned it
all of it
everything you have oh my god
you didn't even know oh god
you could come after me
and if you succeed in taking me down
well
you're still obligated
to refinance the entire op shack which
begs the question can you
[Laughter]
maybe uh open a tiki bar in one of the
lesser-known caribbean islands and live
your life far from me and mine
i um
think it over
i'll be nearby
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
nate
[Applause]
resourceful
resourceful guy
stay down
oh
i love it
showdown
oh dude
oh
gang's all here
oh
[Music]
oh my god
[Laughter]
i love it
safety first
there's so many great little production
design details here
oh
jesus oh [ __ ]
awesome dang and that uses the kickback
great shot
mvp
oh
ouch
[Music]
jesus there we go there's your john
wickmuffle gunkata
i got the gun back
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a sick family
twisted
[Music]
i'd love to see it behind the scenes on
that
[Music]
no
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
that was a great shot there's some
amazing action shots in here
whoa oh my god he is that is bad
wow
gross
oh yeah the beginning of the movie
i forgot all that
[Music]
was the kitty becca it's me i
owe you
who the [ __ ] are you
nobody that ain't much of an answer
yeah yeah what
let him go
ask no further questions
and get that cat some more food
[Music]
he just took out a whole russian
operation
you should be thanking this man by
chance
you name it this kitchen's got it and
with that we've
i'm sorry
that's okay i know they're life go ahead
thanks give them the house yeah no
questions asked yeah
for you
hot shear
does this house have a uh
a basement
cool
snap diggity
that's great
terrific
the flew by absolutely i really flew by
damn
david admirable train for waiting for
post credits now all righty there's
gotta be one it's gotta be a setup for
the future john wick crossover we just
watched the setup for the future another
setup for more futures that's his
personal future i'm talking about the
franchise future he got a call from the
unknown and
so we don't know exactly what it is but
that being that he's being contacted
about something all right fine then i'll
change my hopes to an innocuous joke
post-credit scene that doesn't amount to
anything
got his daughter the kitty
it's like a wolfman story it absolutely
is yeah sometimes a little more of a
rhythm i feel like there's a post-credit
scene coming yeah
tell me again about that guy who shot
him stairs
was three guys pops three
i still don't believe you well it still
happens why can't we just fly there with
this luggage
[Laughter]
sick sons of [ __ ] it's in the family
man that is hey man i mean did grandpa
probably her dad to them probably uh
taught him how to do that three guy
sniper shot
i love it the whole thing is wolf in
sheep's clothing it's like the entire
movie this guy who's
it's who literally is born into being
this person
and he wants something else but it is
just a veneer
yeah it's like a werewolf movie where
you watch where you meet someone who's
actually already sort of conquered their
affliction only to then discover
they actually want to lean into it and
let it back out
i mean yeah they haven't but it's like
he's hungry that's what that first act
is he's just hungry
for more he wants
he wants to feed again um
yeah
yeah no yeah yeah it's that that blood
hunger
it's like once he gets that first taste
he holds back it's like oh it starts the
jones you know but there is a
yeah like that it was a moral conundrum
because it was it was a weird
turn on things when
the couple breaks in they heard the
russians in it and the girls sounded
russian when she first started speaking
i was like oh the latinos
but i thought it was an interesting turn
of events of how
he goes in there and he
decides like okay kitty bracelet was
taken
felt the shame it's time for him to get
revenge
just lets them go that's the end of
what happened there with that couple who
came in and kicked off this whole event
for him in his life
and they just stumbles onto something
else because it they brought it back to
he just wants to feed it's not about
getting revenge
you know and i thought like oh what an
interesting turn i thought it was gonna
be like oh john wick like kind of
someone breaks in and then he's here to
get revenge now and oh but he took
revenge on the wrong people and it's led
to all this
so i thought it was kind of a cooler
through line that it's this all stems
because he just had to get back to who
he was
you know yeah it's like a super personal
journey like you they set up all these
things and i'm sure that they do factor
in like oh man i've just got to prove
himself to his son he's got to you know
like re-establish himself as you know
like the alpha of this family but it's
really not about that at all i wish they
brought some of that back at the end
yeah or something with his son yeah
since that was that seemed to be a
definite focus
of a big part of what he was feeling
ashamed about was wanting to be like
feel like a man in front of his family
in front of his son especially
you know i think we got like
uh enough you know like when he sees
he's all messed up he's like hey i'm
proud of you hey tackle that guy then
his son comes up and sees like oh my god
my dad's a badass my dad took all these
dudes but i didn't want a moment with
him and his son just like something like
even if it was like a
an exchange of looks between each other
like that is his son really you you get
that emotional beat is i guess is what i
sort of wanted
that's also like he i like how it's it's
both like you he loves his family and
he's really soft and sensitive towards
them i just think freaking bob odin
plays
those nuances so well yeah
and those uh it's officially over
we'll continue talking about it now
i think he plays this those um nuances
so incredibly well
of
it's like when he wipes off the board of
like 240 days till uh since it's an
accident or something happens
you know like a lot of movies that try
to have a little bit of that humor to
their shoot em up flicks can be a little
excessive and like i get the joke you
know like sometimes i
it felt lived in here versus
i got the joke all right he's a family
man yeah they didn't do an insert on it
and make it a whole moment it's that
thing of like you could almost miss it
if you weren't really fully aware or of
or paying attention to what the gag is
it feels really natural the way
everything works in that regard of him
being a family man like
of how like
something like the movie shoot him up or
something like mr mrs smith might overdo
it like
i get your husband and wife and your
family jokes you know hey it's kind of a
cartoon it's heightened and you're
having fun with that i understand i
thought they did it just enough in here
to the point where it never became
annoying and would come at surprising
moments
and there wasn't like an uh it wasn't
like ever a moment of
over bantering yeah even amongst the
family dynamics it gets a little
far-fetched for me when old man
christopher lloyd shows up at the end
and it's like no one can shoot him
around
[Music]
it's fun it's funny
it's a little i was
the one who got shot
um
but yeah like i thought the mobile
reason the chair and the russian guy
show up and he like pulls out his
sawed-off shotgun and blasted i thought
that was a cool moment and but yeah when
he's at the warehouse itself i'm like
it's a little much but that's so cool
yeah yeah yeah yeah you've earned it you
were in this movie yeah and i mean it it
adds because of just the scenario and
because of like christopher lloyd like
the presence that he brings just because
we know christopher lloyd and then too
yeah he is as much performances yeah
yeah yeah like there's a charm and a
cheekiness to that that is
just in fitting enough with the movie to
make it okay it's like it's it's
the movie has some hype but like you you
name check those other movies and it's
not going for that level of craziness
and so i feel like yeah it approaches
with christopher lloyd maybe the ceiling
of that but it doesn't for me go beyond
to the point where i'm like i'm kind of
pulled out of this now you know
yeah cause when i saw the trailer it
came back to me just now i remember with
the kitty kitty bracelet moment
like you're really that guy said
[ __ ] like when he's screaming i
thought the movie was going to be that
the whole time instead of john wick's
dog it's his daughter's bracelet yeah i
thought it would just be a bunch of
jokes about him like
you know being a family man too and but
it wasn't you know it really wasn't it
felt like that's just to his character
as it felt like a person we were
watching
accept himself like this was this bob
owner crooks really great at playing
those relatable guys who have uh
walk around with a sense of shame you
know and it's a shame of like what his
past is but he's also not proud of who
he is now because he's got to repress
who he really feels like he is
internally and as this wolf man story is
going on he by the end accepts who he is
and looks like he repairs his marriage
and is able to have a fresh start while
being on the stage of acceptance
of the kind of man that he really is and
he got to show his family too so i think
it's a this is a cool story and i did
find myself legit concerned for him at
one point i was i was actually worried
whereas when you compare it because this
is the same right from john wick and the
movie was constantly compared when i
heard it where as opposed to um
you know john wick i'm never really
worried for john wick in that film word
for everyone else yeah because the way
he fights
he escalatingly gets smoother throughout
this film yeah you know watching a guy
literally shake the dust off yeah
because in the first bus fight he's
getting his ass kicked quite a bit um
but he's he's like rocky balboa you know
he brawls he's bulldogging like no
matter and i think that's what's cool
distinguishing the fighting styles he
just gets in there rough and tumbled in
style you know he's not clean about it
but by the time you get to the finale
where he is very strategic about it
that's when he's at its smoothest with
how he handles everything and so i think
it's cool to watch a guy go through
rough tough and then
like that first fight
he gets hurt a lot he gets thrown
through the window you know
and then the second fight at his family
home it's still kind of like that gets a
few hits on him and then by the time you
get to the finale it's just like oh no
he's he's he's bad
he's who he's he's who he says he used
to be yeah yeah absolutely yeah i mean i
think that it does really nicely to
separate itself from john wick
especially in that way of yeah you have
like with john wick when it kicks off
it's like oh his skills haven't aged a
day you know like he is completely kind
of ready to jump back into this whereas
here you're watching this internal
debate happen throughout and i really
like like it's realized in dialogue it's
realized in scenes but i think a lot of
it is mostly in the performance
of just the internal stuff that bob
odenkirk is really good at throwing out
there so that yeah you are watching this
sort of back and forth within this man
and i love the way they handle the the
initial robbery because it as the movie
goes on picks up this quality where it's
like okay in that full sheep's clothing
mode it's probably look i know what i'm
capable of these are just two punks who
are you know desperate and afraid i
don't want to destroy them right now but
also that comes at a cost of yeah it's
the over correction and so it is
fascinating to watch
a hitman movie where the point i feel
like there's so many like hitman or x
badass brought back into the fold movies
where it's about
obviously the tension between the normal
quiet life and the killer but here it's
less about picking one or the other or
or it's really yeah just about leaning
into that and finding the most
actualized life for yourself based on
what you're good at and what you love
yeah and i love yeah the way that it's
more about striking the balance rather
than it is about i gotta get out and do
one last job or i'm back and i gotta you
know prove supremacy it's like
you get the sense that when he gets the
call he's actually a little bit bummed
to have to like
go back to work so quickly yeah and so
yeah like they really pinned together uh
the the at-home stuff and the
nitty-gritty you know violent action
stuff into what feels like a
well-rounded complete package for the
most part yeah storytelling wise i think
they really cared about that a lot
i thought it was just going to be a big
style over substance with a great bob
odin correct movie yeah performance i
thought that's what it was going to be
like a great bob motocross performance
in a super stylish film yeah i was kind
of surprised by oh you you care a lot
more about the character storytelling
than i expected yeah expecting it to be
one of those scenarios where it's like
the cast really elevates like a pretty
straightforward script but yeah it's
like the scripting i thought had a
thoughtful quality to it along with all
your cool action movie tropes and
foreign
coming out of hardcore henry yeah i
really appreciated this movie's
restraint because there are i mean yeah
obviously that guy has a knack for
stylish action but i thought that it
avoided for me at least
doing too much style only for the sake
of style like you could argue that shot
where the gun flips and then rizzo
catches it it's just like super cool you
earned that at the finale at the finale
it's like yeah you're unleashed at that
point but there are so many great really
deliberate just like pans or warner
shots that serve to really sell the
action and to really make it feel
tangible and coming out of something
that is so kinetic and fran and frenetic
and frantic like hardcore henry to see
something like this that is like really
restrained and then hulks out when it
needs to like it really does
in a completely action movie kind of way
embody that sort of seething simmering
anguish at the heart of like a werewolf
kind of story so like i thought this was
a cool growth for that guy as a director
as well you know well it's like the
first the only one or that you have of
this movie is the one with the
introduction of the of our villain the
russian bad guy yeah
and it is a great introduction you know
that's something i don't want to make
this just a
john wick competition i think the reason
why i'm doing that is because that's all
i heard about this movie this like it
was just constantly compared and i get
it like it's a dude who's a formerly a
hitman
and then fights the russians yeah like i
totally see why people compare i can't
disregard that um it's but there are
things here that i think like store like
when you think about john wick that's a
different type of movie in the sense
that that's a
not as funny in the in in the way how
this is more overtly funny and also it's
um like there's more of like a fun pop
zest to this film yeah versus that
ironic humor yeah yeah exactly and
that one the motive for what he's doing
is very different uh like john wick is a
pure revenge film
where this is it comes from a
selfish desire essentially is where this
comes from and then it becomes about
protecting yeah you know
and so and i hear that word will smith
really ruin that word for me
so he's coined that phrase now um
so yeah it's a very different type of
thing and i think too with terms of your
russian bad guy i'd say for the most
part does he lose uh some of the
threatening weight as the movie
progresses yeah by the time freaking bob
odenkirk shows up
at the club at the club is incinerating
the money and everything you're like
okay this guy's not threatening
ain't got [ __ ] but at first you know it
is it is threatening and the way they
build him up i think is really cool uh
that they they do that's when i was i am
a little concerned because the way they
they um
the picture they paint of the kind of
batty he is
sounds scary and the kind of guy you
wouldn't want to mess with
and i think the way they
they fleshed out the um
uh
the world that
our main character comes on is this
hutch is real actual name um but
okay the way they flesh out the world
there was some noise going out there the
way they flesh out the world that hutch
comes from i think the way they they
spread out the little bits of
information about his backstory was
really well done like how he just tells
a son up front like
i was an auditor
and
yet sounds like it was it's his cover
story
and then you find out that that's
actually what he was titled yeah and why
he was titled that i'm like oh that's
really cool because he could just be
upfront with his i was an auditor but
not the kind of auditor you actually
think he was and the way they handled
the backstory with his wife like it
sounds like his wife
knew something about him
because she wasn't surprised when she
saw him and she was you know tending to
his wounds and we don't know much about
how they met necessarily but the way
they allude to what they were like at
the beginning when starting a new
starting a life like this was exciting
for him when starting a family was
exciting for him and then now that he's
just only doing that how that it's lost
a lot of that flavor for them
and even that cliche assassin story of
the day that changed was the day he
didn't kill this guy because he heard
his story but i thought the way that
played out and how that influenced his
decision to do the family i'm like oh
that's fresh like it's very cliche to be
like you had the gun to the back of the
guy's head and then he couldn't pull the
trigger for some reason yeah
and then for him to like do the whole i
caught up with him saw he was actually
he cleaned up and he has a family life
and that that made him want to have that
as well
i think is refreshing there's a lot of
unique things i think they did here and
they they kept the life throughout and i
feel like visually there was a lot of
cool like visual illustrations that they
they point out that an average audience
member i think could latch onto
you know they they framed a lot of
the way him and his wife are
a lot of the shots were like they're
separated yeah there's usually something
that is a divide it's like a physical
divider between them yeah
the pillow or the car when they're in
the garage you know yeah yeah barriers
and use of negative spaces or like
claustrophobic framing you know when
they're talking to each other directly
yeah but i wanted to see some there are
some wrap ups that i would have liked to
have seen like i wanted to see the
daughter get the kitty i wanted to see
the daughter get the kitty bracelet i
wanted
something with the sun there are some
emotional beats i cared about that i
cared about the family stuff yeah for
sure so i wanted a little bit of buttons
there
um but it i it would be a lie to say i
left dissatisfied by the time it ended
well this reminded me
kind of of how
i almost feel like hitman movies like
this are sort of like garage rock where
it's like yeah there are like a lot of
pieces of this a lot of the chords are
the same as like a million things you've
seen but when you put them in an
interesting order and you put in a few
interesting flourishes something can
feel quite new and when you have enough
unique little twists on the idea like
like you were talking about with letting
that guy go like that's when these
things can really sing and it is simple
and all it takes is some expressive
communication of the themes of the story
through the filmmaking i feel like this
is a good example of one that didn't get
too lost in the weeds of you know
putting a bunch of cool effects and
filters and stuff like that it just went
with okay what's the song we're playing
how do we accentuate it the most while
also keeping it straight forward and to
the point and uh and yeah like
how would you describe the the choice of
songs like i feel like you would bet be
better at articulating let me attempt
and then
you
re-write what i'm saying
is that i think the choice of songs
because obviously they're the choice of
songs our character is using in this
movie they feel
like because they're such oldies music
you know they're from such a different
era kind of like the bygone era of our
character as well so i love that it was
constantly those were the needle drops
of the film yeah yeah i think you're you
know i think you're absolutely right
it's like it's hearkening they sound
like you know they're peppy and they are
you know warm and inviting and they feel
they are of an older time so it feels
like something more quintessential and
classic like you know the american
family household or whatever but also in
the lyrics
you know i don't feel very intentional
yeah it doesn't i don't have a great
recollection of every song but i feel
like the irony and the clever part about
choosing those is that yeah they have
this familial home equality within the
sound but when you dig within the lyrics
they actually seem to be speaking to
these things that actually want to get
out of him or to you know be sort of
acknowledged and that's the thing that
music is really great at is you know is
carrying a certain level of dramatic
irony when you contrast what the lyrics
are saying with the sound and i feel
like this it's like there's that there's
that one moment where they use
heartbreaker which is like a pretty
badass you know it's like that's your
quintessential action movie rock tune
moment and i thought that was placed
nicely amid all these other ones because
yeah
it's sort of the duality to me of his
life is sort of the sound is something
he he does care for and he does want
that warmth and when he's looking
there's that one shot and i don't
remember if it was underscored with
music but where he's looking into the
house the warm light is bathed on him
but he's outside everything is really
cold and so i feel like the lyrical
content does a good job in those songs
of complimenting the theme of what his
character is experiencing feeling
wanting to let out without being
like a song choice where it's like oh
you chose this for the lyrics i get it
you know yeah yeah yeah i thought they
were they're well chosen yeah it's an
excellent film i think for what it is
and uh i think it's freaking excellent
and um
the it becomes a little cartoony with
rizza and the dad yeah a little cartoony
but there's something also charming
about it
yeah it's a family reunion stuff yeah it
is
and i like the cam even though a lot of
the chemistry form with rosa is through
the um
kind of player is that oh yeah i'm not
i'm not 100 sure but yeah just like an
old-time radio transmitter yeah a lot of
the communication is formed through that
i think there is a good chemistry there
by the time he shows up it's really
rewarding one even the use of that like
when he when you're used to seeing him
on that and then he calls him on the
phone and he's like you just want to get
this number traced yeah like yeah it
communicates the urgency even just
through that motif you know true
well chosen guys what do you think about
the movie nobody leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit
that like button
and hey let's do a page
david gandy i just wanted to say thank
you for inspiring this biopic of your
life i feel like if anybody out there is
itching to let the beast out it's you
david you got such a lovely demeanor
you're a kind good-hearted guy and
that's that's you
but you're also a successful
accomplished martial artist and i feel
like you probably have a little pent-up
rage that you need to go out there on
the streets and just let out
you know you're like family to us and i
would feel very safe in your care and
hey if you could teach me a thing or two
i would be very grateful no you're not
going to have me looking at you like the
sun in this movie i'm just going to be
all admiration david gandy so i hope
you're
staying well and kicking ass out there
and we'll catch you next month catch you
david
[Music]
you